Speaker 2: The new thing seems to be fat shaming
people who have abandoned the Trump cult.
Last week, I played a video for you, which
we'll review later of Donald Trump going
after William Barr, who is still a right wing
nut. I mean, William Barr is still a right wing
nut. But William Barr has said, you know, this
classified document stuff is crazy and Trump
didn't win the election yet. Will, William
Barr has stated some factual things. Trump
said all he wanted to do is he. So the next
one is that now Trump is fat shaming Chris
Christie. Now Chris Christie is obese. That's
absolutely true, but so is Donald Trump. And so
there's a couple of different factors to this,
and we're going to talk about that in a moment.
Donald Trump, this is Yahoo! News, actually a
Business Insider, it seems Donald Trump shares
fat shaming photo of Chris Christie untruth
social following critical Mar-A-Lago interview.
Donald Trump shared a photo on truth social of
a large man leaning over a buffet counter. He
captioned the post Chris Christie at a Roy Rogers
at 11 in the evening trying to console himself.
Trump has been accused of fat shaming Christie
after Christie gave a critical ABC News interview.
Now, we don't know who the man in the picture
is. Take a look at this picture. Just see if
you're watching. It really does look like Chris
Christie and I've been in a room. This is so it
sounds like I'm joking, but I've been in a room
that had a food station with Chris Christie when
we were both that politican and behind the
scenes, they had a whole food thing for us.
It does look like Chris Christie. I mean, I
don't know whether it's Chris Christie or not,
but Donald Trump posting Chris Christie at a
Roy Rogers at 11 p.m. in the evening trying
to console himself. And, of course, he is just
attacking Chris Christie for being obese. Here
is the clip I mentioned of him going after
William Barr because Barr is overweight.
Speaker 3: I haven't looked at the recently
concluded states that we have these we still
have people, attorney generals, that don't know
how to do their job. They really don't want to do.
Speaker 2: All he wanted to do. Is it? So
there's a couple of things here. Number one,
the criticisms of the people that have abandoned
Trump have to be like this, because even though
they're still people I don't agree with, you know,
John Bolton, William Barr, Chris Christie and some
of them haven't even really abandoned Trump.
Some of them have just said, I like Trump, but
he's wrong about this one thing. Their criticisms
of Trump are completely substantive in almost all
cases. And so it's not like Trump can come back
at them with anything substantive because he would
just be lying, which he has no problem doing. But
it would sort of be very obvious. So instead, he
has to go to this type of stuff, oh, he's fired.
He's having this this different type of thing.
That's one part of it that he's focusing on this
because there's really no substantive response
to the things that these folks are saying.
The other part of it is that Trump is obese,
and so Trump making fun or attacking others
because they are overweight is also weird. And,
you know, I don't know that I need to give you
these numbers necessarily, but just to kind of
like check my math. Trump claims to be six foot
three and 239. Now, that would put him like us
right on the edge of being obese according to BMI.
Now, BMI is not a perfect metric. We know that if
you're a bodybuilder, a BMI will say you're
obese and that's not relevant or accurate in
any kind of operational sense. But for a lot
of people, it gives us kind of an idea. Now,
I don't believe Trump six three and I don't
believe Trump is 239. And most people don't.
We know Trump's not six three because Barack
Obama is six two and Tom Brady is six four.
And when Trump's next to Brady even wearing what
with it's pretty widely known, Trump wears lifts
wearing whatever shoes Trump wears. He's
notably shorter than Tom Brady. Notice So
he's nowhere near six three. Brady six four. And
he seems to be about the same height or slightly
shorter than Barack Obama. So when you know
that and you say, well, Trump is conservative,
Trump has to weigh at least 255. He might weigh
to 65 if Trump is six two or six one and weighs
255 or 264. It's all obese. It's all obesity. So
do I care that Trump's obese? No. Trump doesn't
exercise and eats a terrible diet, and it's kind
of not shocking. But he's going after people a
lot because they are obese or overweight when
he himself is, of course, as well. So this is
another, you know, what are the principles that
we continue to see? Republicans claim to have
one set of principles and abandon them when it's
inconvenient. Trump, Trump and other Republicans,
they love to make allegations, which we later
learned were actually almost like confessions
of the things they were doing or the things
that they plan to do themselves. Voter fraud,
trying to steal an election they didn't
win is, of course, at the top of the list
and also claiming that they're about policy and
substance and whatever else, and then fat shaming
their political opponents when they can't come
up with anything substantive to say. So their
principles actually don't matter. They only care
about their principles when they are convenient